The jogan Experience did you uh were you
at UFC Miami earlier this year how crazy
was it when Trump walked out insane I've
never experienced that it's like I was
like it was more crazy when he walked
out in Madison Square Garden really yes
jeez the Masson scare Garden one La the
last fight was [__] bananas dud it's
unbelievable I never heard a crowd like
that over a minute of people screaming
at the top of their lungs as he's
walking in nuts this country is fed up
yeah this is a Fed Up country where you
know the mainstream media can say all
the [__] they want they're trying but
the people aren't buying it no you and
that's the perfect example right there
is you know 20,000 people or whatever
like losing their minds when the dude's
walking to the cage it's like there's no
fighter that gets that but yeah the
country it's like you can tell you just
talk to people or or see what's going on
it's like you could tell well you know
there's people that voted for Biden that
are doing it now they're like what did I
do right what did I choose like how is
this guy yeah you just can't listen to
an interview or he's saying some of the
stuff he says that just makes no sense
at all it's like you can't listen to
those interviews and feel like you made
a good decision I I don't know how did
you hear what he said like yesterday a
couple days ago said he talking about
the Revolutionary War he's like one of
the reasons why we lost a revolutionary
war one of the problems with the
Revolutionary War was they didn't have
enough airports
yeah ever seen that I saw that like like
pull
him if you were if you had any other job
and you were talking like that they
would go hey you're done if you talk
like that to a doctor at your medical
exam for to fight they' be like okay
like obviously you're not
fighting you would also here's you know
eight weeks of of being helped out by
professional like right you might not
ever do anything again no it's it's it's
one of the wildest Things ever it's
insane and the the media gaslighting you
to protect it's just people are so
afraid of trump being in office and
Republicans being in office you know
it's funny cuz um right after uh after
my last fight he was he was uh cage side
with Dana and uh then I got back home
and he invited me out to uh Bedminster
in Jersey and was like come golf with me
coolest freaking dude man he was like I
was we we didn't talk about politics we
didn't talk about anything when I first
got there rolled up I mean there's 30
secret service members um you know
everybody's doing their thing and he did
a few like uh kind of worked with one of
his secretaries like make some
announcements and do some stuff but then
we just golfed for like four hours rode
in the cart with him and he was like the
coolest guy so with it so smart asking
me about fighting we're talking about
you know all boxing we talk about
football talk about Golf and he was so
sharp and with it and uh it was me this
is like the craziest thing like
I'm from like I grew up in a town of
5,000 people in Wyoming now I'm fighting
in the UFC and then with Trump golfing
it's me Trump uh OJ Anderson who's the
NFL running back Super Bowl MVP and LT
like that's the for that's the forsome
and I'm like wow what the heck is going
on here but that's got to feel surreal
it was super surreal and what nothing
really like he was such a bro and so
cool and so with 70 I think he 70 Upper
70s and
couldn't believe how smart and sharp the
guy was like I was like wow like this is
bizarre right right like super with it
he's the only guy that went through four
years in the white house and didn't seem
to age no everybody gets in that white
house and they just fall apart their
hair gets gray they look tired all the
time they just like like the weight of
the world which it literally is is on
their shoulders I think he just he loves
it [__] duck to water he's like he's
like what are you going to say come on
like oh it was this was the craziest
thing so him and LT were playing like a
th000 bucks a hole or something and uh
he smoked him on Trump like people I
golf with him the dude's amazing golfer
I couldn't believe it how how good he
was every Fairway right down the middle
hit every Green making all those putts
and uh so he won the first nine like
pretty easy and then the last nine um it
was going in the 18th hole uh him and LT
were tied or something it was like the
the winner it was like all came down to
this last hole and they both hit great
drives and LT hit like a good um
approach shot and Trump gets it there
gets up there he's probably like 150
yards from the green and uh he sets
up just Stripes it straight at the pin
Ball's like in the middle of the arc
like not even not even coming down yet
he turns around doesn't even watch it
land walks right back to the cart sits
down and uh the K is like nice shot Mr
President and I was like damn that was
clutch and he looks at me he goes don't
you want your present to be
clutch and I was like for sure man and
he hit it 2 feet from the pin and tapped
it in and I was like
jeez slick it was slick I was like it
was just cool dude though it was funny
it's a weird time cuz there's people in
this country that want to think he's
Hitler I know it's uh it's very strange
you couldn't convince me otherwise just
hanging out with the guy I'm like man
well you know it's just the media
narrative I mean so many people were fed
this lie that he the Russia collusion
was this was this the video you're
talking about let me see what this one
says I don't think it
is what by the way the same stable
genius who said the biggest problem we
had in the Revolutionary War is we
didn't have enough
airports
whoa yeah that's
it just for for the record is that fake
it's not fake but he was referencing
Trump saying that here's what Trump
saying it in 2019 Donald Trump said
something about that he didn't say G
Jesus he said a stable genius and that's
where the the transcription let me hear
what it says what did he says in June of
1775 the Continental Congress created a
unified Army out of the Revolutionary
forces encamped around Boston and New
York and named after the great George
Washington commanderin-chief the
Continental Army suffered a bitter
winter of Valley Forge Found Glory
across the Waters of the Delaware and
seized Victory from Cornwallis of York
town our army manned the air it ran the
ramparts it took over the airports it
did everything it had to do oh okay yeah
so he [__] up yeah he did but I feel
like you can tell too it sounds like a
little different he's like you could
tell he like messed up his words but
yeah he was just I don't know took go
over the airport well that's the thing
about that's the thing about media these
days it's like right you got to look
into
it